con el paso de los días la ayuda
internacional y local va llegando a Los
afectados por el terremoto del pasado
lunes por la madrugada pero no lo hace
por todos por igual tanto
geográficamente como por personas ahora
mismo nos encontramos en osman y uno de
los campos que se han creado para ayudar
a las personas que se han quedado sin
casa muchos de aquí son turcos pero
también hay muchos sirios recordemos que
esta zona afectada por este terremoto es
una de las zonas donde más refugiados
viven en Turquía la mayoría de ellos
incluso viven en estas zonas afectadas
hablando con algunos de estos sirios nos
explican que aquí están recibiendo ayuda
mantas comida agua y todo lo necesario
que sin embargo son culpados por muchos
turcos de ser incluso responsables de
este terremoto y reciben insultos y
algunas amenazas por las noches
recordemos que los últimos años en
Turquía a medida que la crisis económica
ha estado afectando al país a anatorio
el racismo y el el resquemón en contra
de la comunidad de refugiados Siria ha
crecido mucho sin embargo esto sigue
refugiados en Turquía tienen mucha más
suerte que antiguos vecinos que se han
quedado en el norte sería y en las
regiones controladas tanto por el
régimen como la oposición sería allí la
ayuda humanitaria llega a cuentagotas y
no están teniendo hay muchísimos
problemas de abastecimiento y de rescate
de personas que aún están atrapadas en
las runas tanto en Turquía pero sobre
todo también en el noreste de